there's other tools that are kind of
interesting we've been talking about
this um
at the psychological level but there's
also a neuroscience perspective if we
kind of like go past the skull into the
brain with the neurons firing
there's ideas of brain computer
interfaces first of all there's a whole
field of neuroscience that's kind of
zooming in and studying the firing of
the brain the firing of the neurons in
the brain
of how from those
neurons emerges all the things that we
think that make us human that's a
fascinating exploration in the human
mind
that that's of course where the
psychedelics have the chemical the
biochemical effects on on those
neurons
there's ideas of brain computer
interfaces which
you know if you look at especially what
neural link is doing with this long-term
vision
with elon musk and your link they um
they hope to expand
he calls it a wizard hat
[Laughter]
this is back to the humor on the
internet thing uh
the the the wizard hat that expands the
capabilities the capacity of the human
mind
do you think there's something there
or
is is the human mind so infinitely
complex that um
we're quite a long way away from
expanding the capabilities of the human
mind
through technology versus something like
psychedelics
i wonder how terence mckenna would
answer that question um
no he looked to shamans as kind of the
the scientists um the high magicians of
the high archaic past and the far-flung
future
i'm not gonna discount you know more
about ai than i do so i'm not gonna
discount it
but
i do think that ai paired with
um
the sacred recovery right
um the archaeology
of consciousness um and these and these
states these archaic techniques of
ecstasy that were practiced across time
i think that's
a winning combination um you know part
of what i do in the book is just
i try and lay out the set and setting
that's often talked about with
psychedelics i mean so
maybe psychedelics in the right ai
environment is going to work i think
it'd probably work a lot better with
that myth and ritual incorporated so the
reason ellucis worked for 2000 years um
and let's assume the psychedelic
hypothesis has some merit to it um but i
think the reason it worked is because
you were born into a mythology you were
born into a story about demeter and
persephone and you waited your entire
life to meet them in the flesh so you
weren't just preparing for a few months
it was a lifetime of expectation
anticipation ritual preparation
in fact some of the early church fathers
made fun of the greeks for essentially
just picking people's curiosity and
revving up the anticipation which has
something to do with the outcome by the
way but in other words i think we need
to create a new mythology
around this i don't think you you pop
into a laboratory i don't think you pop
into a retreat center um from one day to
the next i think that in my own case i
feel like i've been preparing 12 years
for psychedelics and i'm still preparing
including in today's conversation i'm
learning new things
and uh i'm willing to explore it you
know together with the computer
interface but i i but i do think ritual
is a is a gigantic part of this and even
mckenna would say that i'll paraphrase
him by saying that if if you'd met
someone who didn't know where they were
between the years 1995 and 2005 you
would describe them as a fairly damaged
person and yet who among us knows what
was happening in western civilization
between 900 and 1300 let alone 2500
years ago so this is in many ways the
profit of the psychedelic renaissance
saying that history has
lessons
and i don't think they're superficial
lessons i think it cuts to the very core
of how and why western civilization came
to be born
yeah but that that history can be loaded
into ai systems and i do love the idea
of
whether it's to bring computer
interfaces or without
intrusive sort of without direct reading
of the neurons and more sort of
interactive experience of the robot
that you can have an ai system that
steers your psychedelic experience
that um
helps you sort of
when you take a heroic dose of
psilocybin for example help steer you
steer your mind say just the right
things i mean you could say that kind of
thing with uh it's a totally open
um
problem i would say
you talk about sudden setting this is
the interesting thing about
johns hopkins is you know you create a
comfortable environment a safe
environment for
allowing then if you take a heroic like
a large dose of psilocybin that you
could
trust that everything would be safe and
you can really allow the exploration of
your mind but then you don't know
from a psychotherapy perspective of like
during that trip what a human should say
to steer that trip like that's a totally
open set of problems and in some sense
probably throughout history those
rituals you figured out what are the
right things to say to each other
exactly how to collaborate and maybe if
you can turn that into an optimization
problem
uh ai could figure that out much much
quicker i'm with you so ellucis was
known for three things the legomena the
dromina the dychnumena the things said
the things done the things shown if you
can pack that all into your ai interface
i'm in lex friedman
i'm going to write a proposal and and
then try to get it through the irb at
mit
i mean there there's a certain sense in
which i definitely wanted to to explore
uh psychedelics i mean in in my personal
life but also more rigorously as a
scientist
and uh to to push that forward and
especially in the ai space and it is um
difficult kind of
how to do that dance
when there's uh gray areas of legality
and all those kinds of things and we're
dancing around them and some of that is
language and some of that is uh
what we socially uh
conceive of as as drugs or not and
you're right that perhaps we can reframe
it as religious experiences all those
kinds of things i mean it's fascinating
because it feels like there's a bunch of
tools before us that were used by the
ancients that we're not utilizing for
exploring the human mind
uh that we very well could be
in a rigorous scientific way in a safe
way and that's fascinating
you